[UPBEAT MUSIC]
Write your truth,
and believe in it.
And if your mother
doesn't like it, too bad.
[LAUGHS]
The novel is creating
a whole new mode
of understanding the world.
Over the last 30 years
of being a novelist,
I've learned how
that's worked, and I've
made a commitment to it.
And I would love to talk to
you about that commitment.
I'm going to talk
to you about how
to choose the right
words, structure, story,
characters to create
the novel that's in you.
The Black male heroes are the
major characters in my novels
because there have
been very few novels
written about Black male heroes.
If you want to be in the
history of the culture,
then you have to
exist in the fiction.
If you don't exist
in the literature,
your people don't exist.
I wake up, write three
hours, 1,000 words.
Next day, the first thing I
do is reread that 1,000 words
I wrote yesterday.
And then I write my
next 1,000 words.
And that goes on and on until
I get to the end of the novel.
If you write every
day, the next day,
ideas have bubbled
up from some place
that you had no idea were there.
One of the great
things about starting
writing for me at the age
of 34 was that I was already
a failure in life.
In failing, you can find out
the right way of doing things.
A lot of you will be
intimidated to start writing.
Throw all that fear
out the window.
It doesn't matter,
'cause it doesn't.
The only thing I need you
to leave this class with
is the confidence that
you can write a novel.
You will write that novel.
I couldn't ask
for anything more.
I'm Walter Mosley, and
this is my MasterClass.